well it was initially given to
uh sir ilyn payne the king's justice who
used it to
chop ned's head off um
and presumably he kept it for a while
till lord tywin got to town and decided
to
to make other uses of it ice is a great
sort of valerian steel
valerian steel manufactured in the
freehold of valeria with dragonfire
before the freehold fell
keeps its edge forever is much lighter
and
stronger than regular steel they can't
make it anymore no one knows the secret
since valeria
vanished but it can be manipulated and
reforged
so lord tywin seizes ice which is a
great sword and he has it
reforged into two
longswords smaller than the big
two-handed greatswords
iron chainmail and steel plate over the
chest
metal gauntlets over the hands and
greaves over the legs
a visored helm over the skull a knight
in full armor can shrug off swords
spears and
axes but valyrian steel slices through
his protections like so much cloth
as advanced design is from bronze so is
valyrian steel from ordinary steel
lighter yet stronger and nothing holds
an edge like it
if you take a wet stone to a valyrian
blade you'll need another whetstone
and maybe another hand to hold it
nobody knows how the valyrians forged
their steel
less than a handful of smiths can now
even reshape it
the process like so much of their
civilization was lost in the doom
many claim they wove magic spells into
the molten metal
and blasted it with dragon fire when you
see a valyrian blade
smoky and dark as if drinking in the sun
and rippling with a thousand folds you
may not scoff so loudly
the valyrian steel that exists now is
all there will ever be
some survives in the citadel with the
maesters chains
where a link of valyrian steel signifies
study of the higher mysteries
whatever those are some drifts through
the world as
prize daggers and jewelry for rich
merchants
i've even seen a dothraki arik but much
more of valyrian steel lives on in the
great houses of westeros
as their most treasured possession a
sword passed down from father to son
for generations ice
of house stark heart spain
of house tarly lady forlorn
of house corbrey but even precious
treasures can be lost
aegon targaryens blackfyre and vicenya's
dark sister
disappeared in damon blackfire's
rebellion
a foolish king of the rock took house
lannister's bright roar to valyria
and neither blade nor man was seen again
and then there are the swords that are
not lost but lose their
owners for five centuries longclaw was
the pride of house
mormont my house even
penniless and in great debt i chose to
sell men
rather than the sword and when my shame
became known and i
fled bear island for the east i left it
behind for my father
to hold it for a worthier air
valyrian steel is a wonder of the world
sharper than wits truer than men rarer
than
virtue but even its edge cannot cut so
deeply as a sun's
failure nor its value match that
of redemption